كان عدم وجود صورة لي أو جسدي
على الغلاف إحدى الطرق التي
بدأت بها نوعًا ما في التفكير في
كيفية التحدث عن هذه الأنظمة دون
الحاجة دائمًا إلى أن أكون فقط في
صورة ذات بعد واحد
[موسيقى
] الصناعة حقًا
يعلمك أنك نوعًا ما
يمكنك استبداله وأنك
تعلم أنه كلما كنت أقل قبولًا كلما قلت
احتمالية توظيفك
وشعرت بالخوف الشديد عندما كنت
عارضة أزياء صغيرة كنت أقوم بذلك من أجل
المال
لذلك أعتقد أنك تعرف أن لديك
حدودًا وأن تكون قادرًا على قول مثل
هذا هو ما يجعلني مرتاحًا
وغير مرتاح ، فهذا شيء تعرفه حقًا
ولكن الشيء الآخر
هو أنني في وضع مختلف الآن أنا
لست  نموذج غير معروف وأعتقد
أنه ليس فقط النماذج التي يجب أن
تغير الطريقة التي يتصرفون بها ،
أعتقد أن الصناعة بأكملها يجب
أن تتغير وبصراحة
يجب أن تتغير الثقافة ككل ،
أعتقد أنه يمكنك أن تكون في الخارج
و  التحدث عنه وانتقاده  وتغيير
الأشياء ، لكنني لا أعتقد أنني سأخطئ أبدًا
أي امرأة لمحاولتها العمل
داخل حدود العالم الذي نعيش فيه ،
وأعتقد أنني متواطئة وهذا ما
أنا مهتم باستكشافه
ولكني أعتقد أيضًا أنه  أخطأ
في معرفة العار على امرأة شابة لارتدائها
فستانًا ضيقًا
تعرفه لأنها تريد أن يلاحظها
شخص قوي أو أيا كان ما
أعتقد أنه
امتداد لنفس كراهية النساء ونفس
النوع مثل مطالبة النساء بالتكيف باستمرار
لقد رأيت الكثير في حياتي ،
فنحن جميعًا متواطئون ، وأعتقد أن
هناك العديد من الأنظمة التي تعرف أن
السياسيين ينتقدون الأنظمة
أثناء العمل أيضًا داخلها ، وأعتقد
أنه من المهم أن نسمح
للناس بفعل ذلك.
لقد عرفت أيضًا أنك وجدت
طرقًا للحصول على التحكم حيثما أستطيع
وكان ذلك مفيدًا حقًا بالنسبة لي ولكن
بعد ذلك
تمكنت أيضًا من استخدام اسمي لكتابة هذا
الكتاب والتحدث عن الأفكار التي
أجدها حقًا مهمة جدًا و  من
منصة ومرحلة أكبر بكثير
لو لم
نسمع كلمات مثل النظام الأبوي والرأسمالية
وأشعر
وكأنه نوع من هذه الكلمات
الكبيرة وهذه المفاهيم الكبيرة ولكني أردت
استكشاف الطرق التي تظهر بها هذه الأشياء
في المواقف اليومية